是一个大龄的单身女生，
这几年原生家庭的问题一直困扰我。
家里有一个弟弟，
父母特别重男轻女，
从小既不支持我读书，
更不想在我身上花一分。
从毕业工作开始，
我弟弟就各种管我借钱，
后来还多次管我借我的支付宝账号，
说是要开一个某宝的店铺，
他自己的账号被封了，
我拒绝了之后呢，
我妈就介入进来，
非得管我借，
出于各种家庭的考虑，
我当时答应借了，
3个人还达成了一致，
就借2年啊，
只是开店铺，
别的事儿不能干。
后来我发现我弟弟拿着我的账号，
嗯，
就搞网贷了，
然后我和我父母就各种吵，
我把我的账号要回来了，
我母亲不愿意，
这个事儿呢，
就持续了三四年啊，
最终呢，
这个账号还是拿回来了，
我发现我的弟弟用我的支付宝借了7万块钱，
后来是我爸妈给他还了，
但我爸妈现在既不想承认又想压我，
亲戚也各种和稀泥，
姥姥就打电话说自己身体不舒服，
让我回去看他们，
现在我全给他们拉黑了。
之前工作的时候有一些男同事追我，
我妈就觉得是我高攀了，
说人家不是那个意思，
是我理解错了，
然后又让我呃，
亲戚给我介绍，
给我介绍的都有大的缺陷，
比如说刚接一年就离的长相很丑，
没有正经工作的，
我跟我妈就因为这事闹。
矛盾，
他又骂我假清高，
现在我和爸爸妈妈亲戚我把他们全拉黑了，
目前对自己的人生就很迷茫，
我不知道直播间有多少女孩子跟这个姑娘相同的，
其实这个姑娘的困境挺典型的，
一、
重男轻女的家庭，
二、
她妈妈。
我觉得某种程度上来说的话，
是有一点艳女情结的，
我不知道直播间有多少女孩子曾经感受过这种来自妈妈的艳女的恶意，
我记得我以前看那个电视剧都挺好，
里面那个苏明玉她妈妈某种程度上来的话，
她就是有点艳女情结在里头的，
就感觉不是盼着女儿过得好，
好像女儿只有过得不好，
当妈妈的心里才舒坦。
如果姐妹我经常在评论区看到，
就是自己当了妈妈之后，
才能够真实的感受到自己是不被爱的，
自己当了妈妈之后才承认这一点，
像这个投稿的这个姑娘啊，
如果在你的妈妈的眼里，
你只配得上一些，
比如说没有正经工作的，
长得丑的，
只配得上这些人的话，
那你确实需要逃离这样的环境，
逃离这样的家庭。
我特别推荐你去看一本书，
这本书的名字叫做基层女性，
同时我也推荐你去。
关注这个博主，
这个博主他叫林玲迪特与四之猫，
他的经历就很典型，
是出生于重男轻女的家庭，
他的爸爸有打庭那个啥就Q续续就打打打那个啥，
然后他基本上是30岁之前挣的钱，
全部用于回馈他的家庭，
还是得不到他妈妈的那种肯定和爱。
但他自己应该是30岁之后吧，
换了各种各样的工作，
结识了不同的人，
开始一路觉醒。
他现在自己有自己的事业啊，
也有自己的粉丝群体，
也有自己的婚姻家庭也经营的很好，
很值得大家去关注，
去看一下。
如果说想要从重男轻女的家庭里面解脱出来的话，
首先要承认自己不被爱，
一旦我们承认自己不被爱了之后，
内心会减少很多纠结和痛苦，
怕就怕你一方面不被爱，
另一方面又不愿意承认，
还对爸爸妈妈抱有幻想，
抱有期待，
那就很痛苦。
你现在之所以迷茫，
就是心里面还有一丝丝的不甘，
就是说还有一点点的想不通，
你什么时候能想通，
我就是那个不被原生家庭爱，
不被父母爱的孩子，
我需要做的是什么？
我需要做的就是在剪断和他们之间的关系的同时，
不背负任何道德的枷锁，
不背负任何情感的障碍，
你才能获得自由。
这句话大家琢磨一下看，
你已经做到第一步了，
第一步就拉黑了他们，
第二步是什么？
在拉黑他们，
剪断他们的同时，
不背负任何道德枷锁，
不背负任何情感的牵绊，
然后你需要做的第三步是成为自己的父母。
把自己重新养育一遍。
如果小的时候你喜欢看电影，
但是他们不让你看，
没带你去看，
你就现在带自己去看，
如果小的时候你喜欢吃甜食，
但他们不给你吃，
你想去哪儿玩儿，
他们不让你玩儿，
不让你去，
你就带自己去玩儿。
如果小的时候你喜欢什么漂亮的衣服，
他们不给你买，
你现在就给自己买漂亮的衣服。
如果小的时候你希望自己有一个温柔的说话非常和气的父母，
但是你没有，
现在就温柔的和气的对自己说话，
且温柔的和气的对别人说话。
你把自己重新养育一遍，
做自己的父母，
那就是择偶。
像这样的原生家庭出来的女孩子特别容易踩坑，
为什么特别容易踩坑呢？
因为你们没有得到过很多的爱，
所以到了社会上，
但凡一个男的主动送你回家，
但凡一个男的主动请你吃饭，
但凡一个男的说给你洗了件衣裳，
你就以为那是爱你，
就以为他是来拯救你的人。
错了，
这个世界上能拯救你的人只有你自己，
只有你自己能解决你生活中的所有的问题的时候，
你才具备了去识别谁是那个爱你的人的资格。
这些原生家庭不好被重男轻女，
被忽略，
甚至被艳女长。
那的这些女孩子，
你们初入社会的时候，
千万不要人家请你吃个饭，
给你披件衣服，
下雨了给你打个伞，
问一下你，
呃，
吃饱没，
你点个外卖呀，
或者说陪你去看个电影，
看到你哭了，
给你递个纸巾啊，
你就觉得这是真爱了，
特别容易从一个火坑跳到另外一个更悲惨的火坑里面去。
你只有当自己能够剪断跟家里的联系，
且不背负任何道德负担，
且你在这个社会上找到了一个你自己能挣钱养活自己的工作了之后，
你能够把自己重新养育一遍，
重新爱一遍，
让自己内心的那个小孩儿在自己的抚养之下逐渐的强大了，
你才有可能识别哪些人是真正爱你的，
对你好的，
哪些人是值得被你去爱的。